Caffe believes you told us previously
that you started out in the studios in a
typing pool and then you started to be
given notes and you realize you were
really in your element
so having having been in the industry
for some time how does the film and
television industry really work you've
seen it from sort of this level of being
a secretary in the typing pool sort of
being an observer maybe in hearing
things that people didn't even know you
were observing and then you from from
working your way up to a much higher
level how does it work well from that if
you want to use as a basis of comparison
I think a lot of it has to do with the
technology first of all a lot of things
that were done on a typewriter are no
longer it's now on a computer so
technology is different I do think that
that there are more people interested in
becoming involved within the studios and
the network's I do see that now there
are one of the things I've really
noticed there used to be 10 to 12
studios and they're now something like 6
6 3 goes something like that there's a
remember we used to have three basic
networks CBS ABC and NBC and look how
many cable stations and how many smaller
networks network for television that we
have we have streaming we have more
areas where a person can get projects
placed so that is great because there's
more opportunities which I think
everyone needs you know so I think that
that's a good thing then that's also a
huge difference from what it was when I
first started off how does it really
work in terms of if you were to sit down
and have lunch with someone that's come
from another state or another country
and they have a vision of it
how would you sort of give them this
maybe 15 minute briefing or less on this
is how it works it's it's either/or sort
of an open system it's a closed system
that this is how the process works of
getting projects approved okay let's
take it just as you know just in sort of
very brief kind of terms
if it were about a script which I think
most I think most of your your fans
aren't interested in screenwriting in
terms of screenwriting it's different
now because you can give your scripts to
other people in terms of like Amazon it
has a little bit more open policy you
don't necessarily have to have an agent
I've heard of people who have just sent
things to Amazon and it's gotten read
there are more opportunities in terms of
there are all kinds of conferences now
where you can pitchfest where you can
make these contacts and network they
didn't have that 15-20 years ago there
were you know there were just very few
opportunities to to be able to have a
writer meet with agents and producers
and executives now there's more of those
opportunities so interesting so then but
most people to present their writing
would need an agent it would have to be
through somebody else except for
webseries and which is another area that
that I think we'll get into a little in
a little while but web series you can
just you could put that on Vimeo you can
put it on YouTube you don't really need
to have an agent in fact most people
don't have agents that are that are web
series creators why so then in terms of
getting an agent are there certain
agents that aren't able to pitch to
studios on your behalf or it's a free
system in that way I'm just trying to
see from let's suppose a total newbies
perspective coming here and thinking
that they could just be basically knock
on the door and see the you know the
person at the front desk and hand it
over that's not really how it works well
you know to get an agent you have to
have material having one scripts not
going to do it no you need to have at
least I would say to its respect scripts
and if you're breaking you the
television I would suggest trying to get
into some of the there's fellowships and
competitions for the major CBS NBC and
ABC they all have
of screenwriting fellowship programs
which you can you know I'll give you a
list of them and you can if your readers
or your fans would like to you know take
a look at them I I have a list of them
for them and they have wonderful
fellowship programs where you can study
with some of their show runners and you
can they'll introduce you to some of the
show runners they'll have them commit
the show runners come in once a week and
talk with these people you know who are
there on the fellowship program and give
them hints and ideas about what they're
looking for how a television series
actually works how they how they put
things together with the casting and the
the plots and how do you continue a
story over a whole not just a season but
a series of years you know they now look
for hopefully at least a five year
season you know five-year commitment for
a television series so they learn all of
those things directly from these people
who are on the front lines so if you can
get into one of those fellowship
programs that's great and so I'll have
I'll have that fell all those websites
for the fellowship programs for you
oh great does it give to your viewers
but in addition when it's when it comes
to agents it's still very hard to get an
agent you can get a manager oh you know
how I told you how things seems to be
shrinking in terms of like the the
network's
the studios same thing with the major
agencies a lot of the agency started
merging about 10 years ago and so they
don't have as many of the larger
agencies like they used to agencies now
have to be very they're very
cost-conscious and so a lot of the
agents when the agencies merged they
lost some of the some dajun's lost their
jobs so they became managers they
started using the term managers and they
also decided they wanted to produce so
there are a lot of managers out there
now so that's another area that you
might want to look into if you're a new
writer
but I'd be careful about it because it
depends on whether they are looking just
for the material or whether they really
want to be able to help you out as a
client some of them are just looking
just for the material they may just want
to do a quick buy of it and have someone
else rewrite it or whatever you know so
you have to kind of be careful about it
because managers are not they are not
regulated
whereas agencies are regulated agencies
you can't charge you can't get more than
10% off of the sale of a client's script
or material and what would be a way to
see if someone was actually a legit
registered agent what website would help
them you can go to the writers guild and
they will tell you they have a list of
the ones who are legit and they will
also tell you the good thing too is if
you do lose up with a manager or a
producer or production company if you
start to think that there might be
something that's not quite right call
the writers skill and they'll tell you
if people have gotten complained about
that I have had I remember when I worked
at Disney someone called me and gave me
their name and they said I'm so and so I
wrote such-and-such script which was
submitted to you six months ago I have
not heard anything and I looked it up on
my computer and I couldn't find it and I
said well what's your agents name and
they told me and it didn't sound
familiar at all and so I said you know
can you do me a favor can you tell me
the name of your script and now and
you're in your name and I said I'll take
all the information down and I will
check and see what's going on I called
the writers guild and they had four
outstanding complaints about this person
who was posing as an agent he said in
fact he said it was an agent slash
manager and he was not registered with
them so a lot of people pay money to
these people and you're not supposed to
pay money this this gal who submitted
her script he was asking for $25.00 for
each submission he would make to a
studio he said okay I submitted it to
four studios that'll be $100
so due diligence call outlay can you
even go on the website yourself you know
like the LA County Bar or or the state
oh you can just fine I can do it that
way too I mean it may take a little bit
longer because they have to pry mean
they get emails all the time where
sometimes if you just make a call you
might catch the right person they might
be able to quickly look it up in their
database okay because I don't know if
they have their whole database on the
website I don't think they knew and for
something like complaints sure that
might be something better to talk to
somebody who's in person who is there
and can look it up for you would you
recommend even if you have a good
feeling about somebody just to just make
sure that everything it doesn't hurt and
hurt okay all right
because the other thing too is one of
the best suggestions I can give to new
writers is during a writers group that
you can do it online now you don't have
to all just live in the same city or
anything you can do it online a lot of
people will trade via email or whatever
and just look at each other scripts and
give feedback and and be a support
system for one another but also for some
of the some of the people who have
actually submitted material or if
somebody has actually got an interest
from a production company they know
whether something works or not and it's
just like the same thing with screenplay
competitions there's so many of them out
there now and a lot of them all they do
is they just get the entry money and
they really don't give you any kind of
value so what I do every year is I I
have several of my clients that that
I've that I do business with and I
always ask them I'll send out a little
questionnaire you know what are some of
the competitions that you feel really
work which are the ones that you think
are the best for new writers to enter
and you know I've put out you know a
little list of that now I'll give that
to you too oh great and it really gives
you a good idea of the ones that's the
most reliable and it really is worth
your time and that's how another writer
would really know if through word of
mouth I think word of mouth is the best
thing because if you know that some if
there's somebody that you know who
actually has gone through a competition
or actually has used an agent or even
and things like it like a consultant you
know like gosh I'm looking for somebody
to you know professional to read my
script you know who can you guys suggest
who have you guys used perfect way to do
it you know because word of mouth is
everything to me you know and that's how
it works actually in the industry when
you talk about agents you know that's
how a lot of people get agents is
because they know someone who knows the
agent and goes by word of mouth that's
one of the best ways if you want to get
an agent but most of us don't know
somebody I mean I want to start on the
business I knew no one in the industry
and so you know I was not able to get a
job that way so the same thing for a lot
of the writers but I have I have clients
who eventually have gotten agents and
it's because they've gone to pitch fest
or because they placed in the screenplay
competition so the form the the best
thing is when you enter these
competitions make sure that they have
reputable people who are the final
judges hmm are these people
agents studio execs Network people show
runners writers you know who are these
people that are doing the final judging
and if they have final judges who are
professionals in the industry they're
going to be looking for clients they're
gonna be looking for material and it's
not unusual sometimes
whoever wins whoever wins the screenplay
competition it may not necessarily mean
that it that that project will get made
but there's always a possibility that
maybe they will ask him what else do you
have or she have you thought about
turning your script in instead of a
movie
how about into a TV series I've had a
couple clients who actually have gotten
agents just because they placed they
place like fourth or fifth but they was
but there are agents who read the
material and saw that there is something
about that material and that writer that
had a voice a different kind of voice
that they hadn't seen so going back to
the judges a a
maybe just just a quick google search of
is this judge working currently in the
industry and that's a good test the
other thing too is sometimes they don't
know until later on whether or not who's
going to exactly be judging who the
exact people are so what you can always
do is to send a little email to them and
just say can you tell me who some of the
judges you've had in the past it gives
you an idea of the caliber of judges
you